The Word Collector.
Collectors collect things.
Some people collect stamps.
Some people collect coins.
And Jerome?
What did he collect?
Jerome collected words.
There were words he did not know the meaning of at first...
...but they were marvelous to say.
There were words whose sounds were perfectly suited to their meaning.
Jerome filled his scrapbooks with more and more of his favorite words.
Jerome's collections grew.
He began organizing them.
One day while transporting them...
...Jerome slipped and his words went flying.
As he began to pick them up, he noticed his collections had become jumbled.
Big words next to little words.
Sad words next to dreamy words.
Jerome began stringing words together.
Words he had not imagined being side by side.
He used his words to write poems.
He used his poems to make songs.
They moved.
They delighted.
Some of his most simplest words were his  most powerful.
Jerome eagerly collected more and more of his favorite words.
The more words he knew, the more clearly he could share with the world...
...what he was thinking, feeling and dreaming.
One breezy afternoon, Jerome climbed the highest hill,...
...pulling a wagon packed with his word collection.
He smiled as he emptied his collection of words into the wind.
Jerome had no words to describe how happy that made him.
The End.